[Applause]
baby
[Applause]
oh
shut up
i can't even see as the black in here
for sure
thank you hey what up c here how are you
buddy
you brought nuggets to the show that's a
bold move
i like that see some good to hear manthi
up front
nice you're confident man you because
you
you wear tight clothes and
you're big you know
[Music]
[Applause]
sahir's clothes look like the net on a
ham
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you for having me everybody uh i
was supposed to be on
earlier in the show but they have to
wait till the sun goes down
so i don't get washed out on camera so
we need a little contrast uh you may not
remember me
but about a half an hour ago uh jonathan
a legend of
didn't know i was on the show i was the
white guy in the crowd that he referred
to you know what i mean white guy
[Laughter]
and
[Music]
we met 15 minutes before that and
i know you didn't confuse me with anyone
else here
and then you gave me permission to say
the n-word which
you gotta have context for that you know
my last name is nickerson
[Laughter]
i've always had a delicate relationship
with that word
you find me a more important k in
history
than the one in nickerson you gotta land
that
you gotta stick that like simone biles
you gotta
[Applause]
no no i'm just here
[Laughter]
i'm just here on the months that kev
doesn't want to pay for gary owen
[Applause]
i'm the budget gary owen i get it
i get it
thank you thank you for having me this
has been a this is fun it's been a year
man what a year
what a stupid year but you know that
little nasdaq story is
encouraging it is it's encouraging me
because i think he's going to bring the
people together
because traditionally worshipping the
devil
is kind of a white person thing it's
kind of
that's been our jam for a long time
that's
we've kind of had the monopoly on satan
worship honestly
i didn't know i thought it was going to
be jesus but it might be lucifer that
brings us together i didn't know
that was what's going to bring the
people but it did
[Music]
i'm glad though that we're kind of
getting through this because it's you
know as bad as the years it's been like
you know everyone's just fighting over
stuff all the time and the mask i'm so
tired of people fighting over the mask
all right like i know a lot of people
are very dramatic about not wearing it
and i think that's hilarious people go
this one you ever heard this one people
don't want to go the mask is a nightmare
the mask is a nightmare really a
nightmare
your life has been pretty good if the
mask is a nightmare
nothing says my parents stay together
like the mask is a nightmare
been pretty smooth sailing for you i
like this one too i
you know i was recently touring the
south they go they give you a hard time
setting certain places for wearing the
mask you know i got this one a lot a lot
they go you know what hey
you know what take that mask off you're
just living in fear
that's what you do when you're just
living in fear living in fear i go
really what are all those guns for
[Applause]
feel like we might all have some
apprehensions in our lives
even the train like that joke yeah yeah
you give me that i don't i can't pull
that off i wish i was good white guy
like
hype energy i wish i was the white comic
that could hype up a black crowd with
like high energy you know like i could
just get up here
you know to the window no that's not me
that's not
[Applause]
it doesn't work it just doesn't work you
know look at me you look at me and you
just
like that guy loves a good acoustic
guitar song about a river
and i do i love a song about a river
[Applause]
it's in my blood
we're all trying everyone's trying in
their own different way you know i'm
pretty excited about everything going on
right now because uh
i heard it's gonna be white boy summer
that's big news that's big news
people have been saying forever that the
problem with society
is poor people having kids have you ever
met a rich kid
tom hanks is the best human on the earth
and his kid is a disaster a disaster
rich white boy summer i don't mean to
break but you know what
all the summers have been white boy
summers
all of them except maybe last summer
that was a bad one for us that
that wasn't our and it started bad it's
cause it started with tiger king spring
and it went downhill it went
and now and now he's acting like we get
like reparations
this is our year okay i had you guys and
then i said reparations and you're like
no we're done there we're done
[Laughter]
we got away we were already tiptoeing
and all right that's my time thanks so
much everybody you guys are wonderful
but yeah i definitely like i like making
people laugh to the point that they
can't clap
that's what i would prefer um
you know i of course don't always do
that but uh
there are guys out there that i've seen
like like it's hard
for like a brian regan level funny guy
when i would watch him live to uh for
the crowd to even
be able to applaud because they're
laughing so hard
yeah he's the first guy i ever saw made
somebody slump over
like there was an empty chair next to
this lady i think the other person
[ __ ] went
ran to the back of the room he was
killing so hard and i like that kind of
laughs the woman was just [ __ ]
i like that kind of laugh where you like
you've seen when i laugh really hard and
if i'm sitting down i get up and i like
run away because i'm laughing so hard
it's so much
i love that kind of laugh that's like
that that apollo
laughter because you know how like black
people like the apollo
if they're laughing really hard they're
like freaking out
like getting out of their seat and just
like waving towels and [ __ ] like yeah
the whole
like hitting each other yeah
like when we think something's funny we
think it's really
[ __ ] funny yeah and when you don't
think it's funny
you really don't think it's funny yeah
that's what i learned during those rooms
black crowd's gonna have fun with or
without you so you you better
basically yeah they're gonna laugh with
you or they're gonna laugh at you
there's no pity laughter there's no
beauty applause no we don't do that
[Laughter]
you gotta be funny
oh some of the [ __ ] heckles i got in
those rooms
the worst is when they would just be
talking to each other about how not
funny you were
i don't forget just on stage just
bombing
it was just dead silence and i just
heard this woman in the middle of the
crowd she just goes she just looked
around and
she just goes i ain't laughed yet
and i was just like oh my god oh
god
[Music]
thank you everybody yeah
thank you for applauding um seriously
because i did a show where they don't
applaud when you go on stage it's called
uh
mo betta mondays at uh that's not even
the show at the improv
moment on mondays it's an all-black
audience and i had done a show called
chocolate sundays
at the lab factory which is an all black
audience and they invited me because
they thought i was black
because of my name because i directed
booty tang so people sometimes think i'm
black
and so they invited me to that to the
show so i get there
and they go oh hi
and then we kind of stand there trying
to decide and i go [ __ ] it hi
yeah hi all right so i went on
and this is chocolate sundaes at the
last factory it was [ __ ] great i had
a great time because nobody else is
trying they're all up there just acting
cool and i went up there and i tried and
everybody appreciated it
so then um because most comedians don't
try i'm not saying because they're they
were black but they were all black and
unfunny
there are far more unfunny white
comedians
than other than unfunny black ones but
every single comedian on that show
was black and unfunny should have been
the name of the choke
but i was white and hilarious and also
you know privileged and uh lucky to be
white
it was a very
everybody whose wife should just wake up
going [ __ ] life is great
how easy is this [ __ ] i don't have to
[ __ ]
explain myself ever
i look people in the eye with confidence
nobody [ __ ] with me police
protect me
it's amazing that black people all they
can hope from the cops is that they'll
leave them alone
we actually get to hope that they'll
protect
a chasm of difference on the and i'm on
the
greatest side of that cat i am on the
[ __ ]
sweet side of that cat
just a fact it's not a nice thing but it
happens to benefit me greatly but anyway
about it oh it sucks being white white
people always complain about something
like oh i don't get to say [ __ ] like
no
white people i can't ever they can say
it to each other but like
they want to go to the supreme court i
should be allowed to say it
somehow it's not right
don't why do you want to say it so fast
anyway so chocolate sundae i didn't
certainly do any of that material there
i just talked about my kids and cars
and then i went to do more better
mondays and i thought i got invited to
do a little bit of mondays and that's
where i became racist i became
prejudiced because i said hey
they'll love me there because i just
thought there's black people in that
building
so the black people in that building
will be exactly carbon copies
there's no way they won't laugh because
they laughed the first time
so i went people were saying moment of
mondays is not nice i'm like
[ __ ] you to just white and i'm better so
yeah
too but i've been there and i got laughs
and white people that
make black people laugh are very proud
of themselves so
so i went to mobile mondays and it's not
at all even close to the same
people they're [ __ ] suburban people
in uh
in chamber sunday's movement on mondays
they have a the
machine and they have they're selling uh
cologne in the bathroom and
people are [ __ ] hard and
they do not clap when they break them on
stage people go on they go how about a
hand for joe or whatever and then he
just walks up
to silence i mean i've never even seen
that on any show in my life
there isn't just the benefit of the
doubt applause they just
bring him up and he just walks up and
people go yeah okay
go
and i went on and uh i didn't pay
attention to the people before me
because they were smart they didn't go
right into jokes they started talking
and [ __ ] they just going hey yeah all
right
yeah i'm just hanging okay for like
three minutes of that [ __ ]
and then eventually go okay they slide
into a joke and get a tiny laugh and by
the end of time they left they go all
right and then they
applaud when the guy left i go on and i
just go and i do a joke right away and
it gets
nothing and not only does it get
silenced when i move on to the next joke
that's when i hear a noise because when
i start going
anyway so they all go oh [ __ ] that was
[Music]
it
like they didn't know the joke was over
even until i started joke number two
joke number one so joke number one
really that's what oh then i do joke
number two and now it's not science like
ah
no man no like literally that sound
coming out of many tables
and then i tried the thing that never
fails when you're bombing i go
oh [ __ ] you people i'm staying up here
that always works when you're bombing
you know you know what [ __ ] you i'm
doing my time and somebody always goes
all right
i give respect to the balls but they all
went no
no no get off what guy
said that just real serious no get off
get off now
i was like okay
i did like a minute total and uh
[ __ ] that hurts so bad man and i was in
the car afterwards just like oh
jesus i didn't mean to tell that whole
story it's just that when you applauded
when i came up here i felt oh that's
nice that helps
that's it sorry
it's too long uh anyway but it's nice to
see you all here and it's
it's kind of funny to see you all
because i [ __ ] all of your mothers